this is a production of Cornell
University
hi this is Frank Rossi for the Cornell
turfgrass video log and we're here at
the end of May talking about some lawn
issues particularly annual bluegrass and
a lot of the broadleaf weeds you're
seeing in your lawn number one a lot of
people are out spray and broadleaf weeds
and you'll start to see them curl up in
the landscape now you want to be really
careful when you're treating for
broadleaf weeds as many of your
ornamentals have a lot of tender growth
going on and that's very susceptible to
herbicide injury so make sure you're
using the amine formulation and of
course you can find out when the best
time for that to use that is on our
Cornell turfgrass website connecting to
the forecast website the other thing
we're talking about and seeing on home
lawns is annual bluegrass seed heads now
you'll see the seed heads develop and
this is the true winter annual form of
annual bluegrass that will produce these
seed heads and the issue is after that
happens you'll see a natural yellowing
of some areas on a lawn and that's
simply because after the seed head is
developed you'll see a natural decline
in this in the stand that tiller is
going to die off after it produces that
flower so keep in mind when you're doing
some weed control to be careful when
you're using those herbicide products
and also if you see some yellowing
happening in your lawn it's likely
related to annual bluegrass seed heads
development and then the natural decline
of the plants is Frank Rossi for the
Cornell turfgrass video log this has
been a production of Cornell University
on the web at cornell.edu